of in the video where we first
introduced the Milankovitch cycles where
we talk about the precession and how the
the tilt of the earth the obliquity can
also change I get this comment here on
the YouTube channel from vixx oma and he
or she says if I understood this
correctly precession changes the time of
the seasons over long periods of time
and obliquity changes the strength of
the season over long periods of time and
so this is a good comment so the first
comment isn't exactly true that's what
I'm going to focus on in this video he
says or she says precession changes the
time of the seasons over long periods of
time this is kind of true but I don't
think in the sense that vixx OMA is
referring to it the second part is
roughly true o blick what changes the
strength of the season over long periods
of time if you are more tilted towards
the Sun in the extreme then yes you will
have a bigger disparity then when you
are less tilted when you are tilted away
from the Sun or I guess you'd say if you
are more tilted to or away from the Sun
the disparity between summer and winter
will be greater than if you are less
tilted so the second statement is true
although although you always have to be
careful with things as complicated as
the climate because it can really depend
from parts of the globe to parts on the
globe depending on what are all of the
other factors that play into it so you
would want to run some type of
simulation or anything or something like
that but the second part is roughly true
but I want to focus on the first part
because I think it'll really give us a
better understanding of what precession
is and so this last statement vixx OMA
makes is actually not true so he says
I'm assuming that he means the Shi so in
a several thousand in several thousand
years not a in several thousand years if
we still use the same calendar system
summer in winter will happen in
different months and they will be more
mild or more harsh what we're going to
see is that the second statement is not
true because our calendar is actually
based on when we are most tilted away or
away towards our way from or towards the
Sun so our calendar is actually based on
is actually to some degree you could say
takes precession into account and what
actually does change is when we are
closest what actually does change
according to our calendar is when we are
closest or furthest away from the Sun
the perihelion or the aphelion and we're
going to think about that in this video
so let me draw the Sun here
let me draw the Sun right over here and
let me draw Earth's orbit around the Sun
and I'm going to draw it with some
eccentricity and just so you have know
what I'm talking about when I say
eccentricity a circle has no
eccentricity and the ellipse this
ellipse right here has more eccentricity
than the circle which has no
eccentricity and an even more eccentric
ellipse would look like this so you can
really think about eccentricity as a
measure of how far you are away from
being perfectly circular
so Earth's orbit around the Sun is
pretty close to circular but it has some
eccentricity it is slightly elliptical
and I'm going to exaggerate it a bit in
this in this drawing right over here so
let's say that this is the closest point
that Earth gets to the Sun so that is
the perihelion and let's say that this
is the furthest point and obviously it's
not this big of a difference it's
actually only a 3% difference right now
but we'll also learn that that's
changing but it never becomes this
dramatic but this will help us visualize
it so Earth's orbit might look something
like this or its orbit let me make it do
a better job than that Earth's orbit
might look something something like this
obviously I'm exaggerating though the
eccentricity here so let's say that's
Earth's orbit this is the point in orbit
where we're closest so that's perihelion
perihelion and this is when we refer
this this is f fillion aphelion aphelion
and we saw in the first video when we
discuss this that right now this
perihelion is occurring in January and
this will change over time as we'll see
in this video so January right now and
aphelion right now occurs in July now
the time where we are most tilted
towards the Sun is not at the perihelion
right now it actually occurs a few weeks
before the perihelion so when we are
most tilted to the Sun this is our
winter solstice this is our wilt winter
solstice and this is when we are
actually in the case of the northern
hemisphere this is when we are most
tilted away from the Sun I should say so
if we were to draw our tilt here if I
were to come out of the North Pole it
would look like that at and this right
over here depending on the year and
where you
our and your time zone and everything
this is usually December 21st or 22nd
I'll just go with December 22nd for now
and when and when we are the northern
hemisphere is most tilted towards the
Sun occurs on June 20th or 21st so
roughly six months later or really
exactly six months later it's just that
all the months have different time and
have different have different numbers of
days and and you have leap year
sometimes with February sometimes having
28 or 29 days but if you go half a year
away then you are at the you are at in
the case of the northern hemisphere the
summer solstice and this is when we are
most tilted towards the Sun this is when
we are most tilted towards the Sun and
once again it occurs right now a few
weeks before the aphelion before we are
furthest away from the Sun now I want to
zoom in right over here on on on
December 22nd so right over here let me
zoom in so let's say that this is the
earth this is the earth I'm zooming in
on this circle right over here so let me
box it to show this is the one I am
focused on right over here and let me
draw let me draw let me draw the axis of
rotation and we know that that angle
versus the vertical that you could call
the tilt or the obliquity and we know
this is twenty three point four degrees
relative to the vertical relative to
perpendicular compared to the act the
plane of our orbit I guess so if we if
we were if we were completely if if our
orbital axis was straight up and down it
would look something like this it's not
it tilts and this angle right over here
is twenty three point four degrees and
when I say straight up and down I'm
saying relative to the plane of Earth's
orbit around the Sun so this right here
is the obliquity and as as vixx Allah
mentioned this does change it kind of
goes between 22 degrees and 24 and a
half degrees over over very long periods
of time but it does I think it's 41,000
years if I remember that correctly so it
will affect on some level the severity
so this tilt is kind of going between
that we're actually it's reducing right
now and it'll get to a minimum in in a
few thousand years
so it'll get to some minimum and then it
might pretend then eventually it'll get
back to some maximum tilt so it kind of
goes back and forth but between those
two over over over the course of several
tens of thousands of years but anyway
this is as it is zoomed in right now and
as we mentioned precession you can kind
of view it as if you you could kind of
view it as if this if this arrow right
here actually existed it would it would
trace out it would trace out a circle
and it's tracing out the circle over a
huge period of time over 26,000 years so
let me make everything clear here right
now I'm just going to assume earth is
rotating in that the orbital Direction
is in that direction I'm going to assume
make that a little bit more curved earth
this is the rotation of the earth it is
in this direction right over here and
what we learned about procession and
actually to be particular its axial
precession there's multiple types of
precession we'll talk about if someone
says just precession they're usually
referring to axial precession it's this
idea that over 26,000 years the tip of
this arrow or you can even imagine the
poles themselves will kind of trace out
a circle if you look at the same point
in our orbit at any period in times the
circle is tracing out is going to be
going in this direction right over here
in this direction right over here so if
we wait 1,800 years and I want to make
sure I get this right because it's
important to see what happens to our
calendar if we wait 1800 years we might
this this this arrow instead of it'll
still have a tilt of point three point
four degrees but instead of pointing in
this direction it might be pointing in
this direction or in fact it it is
likely it will be pointing in this
direction I'm obviously not drawing it
that exact and then the bottom of the
hour will come out over here so if you
think about that if you wait 1800 years
and once again the tilt hasn't changed
or has changed a little bit but what's
what the precession has done tracing out
the circle has changed the direction of
this arrow change the direction of our
axis of rotation and if you wait 1800
years when will when will be pointing or
when will the Northern Hemisphere be
pointed most away from the Sun well now
it won't be pointed most away from the
Sun at this point
in space relative to the Sun anymore
because now it's axis of rotation looks
something like this looks something like
this so now if we wait organized to say
in 1800 years it'll be most pointed away
or the northern hemisphere will be most
pointed away from the Sun about a month
earlier so about a month earlier it'll
be most pointed away from the Sun about
a month earlier so this is when it will
be most pointed away from the Sun but if
we - today's time we would say no that's
still not the most pointed away but
since we have this precession since the
direction of the of the tilt I guess we
could say or the the direction of our
axis our rotational axis is changing we
are now we we are now at a different
point in orbit where we're most pointed
away from the Sun and so this is 1800
years later 1800 years approximately
1800 years later so now based on this
and I think this is what Vic's almost
might might have been hinting at you say
look okay it's earlier on our orbit
wouldn't this now be like wouldn't this
now be like November and the answer is
no it will still be December 22nd this
will still be this will still be
December 21st or 22nd depending on the
year still be December 22nd still will
be the same date and that's because our
calendar is based on when we are most
tilted away or when we are most tilted
towards the Sun so by definition this is
when we're most tilted away so this will
be the winter solstice so what happens
is every year so the way I drew it right
over here and actually this perihelion
actually changes over time as well
there's a precession of the perihelion
as well but I'm not going to go into
that right now so if you fast-forward
1800 years all that's going to happen is
that what we consider by our calendar to
be December 22nd in an absolute point in
in our orbit will be earlier in our
orbit but we're still going to call it
December 22nd and so the perihelion is
going to be further away from that
December 22nd it's actually going to be
a month further away so the perihelion
eighteen hundred years from now won't be
in January it will be
it will be in February so the real
takeaway here is that our calendar is
based not on the exact point in space
relative to the Sun our calendar is
based on the the maximum tilt towards or
away from the Sun and that as we see
that that is slightly changing in terms
of where it occurs on the absolute point
in space I think it's changing by
roughly 20 minutes a year so every year
the perihelion is getting 20 minutes
later if we wanted to use the perihelion
if we wanted to use the exact point in
space if we wanted to use the exact
point in space as our calendar our year
would actually be about that I don't
know what it is roughly 20 or 25 minutes
longer but it actually makes a much more
sense to think about it from the tilt
because that's what dictates the seasons
and that's actually what's most
observable from Earth where earth where
the Sun is in the sky